former Donald Trump propagandist Stephen
Bannon is desperate desperate for Trump
to stop with the nft digital trading
cards and there are actually slightly
more and more voices that are saying ah
some of this stuff is not going going
particularly well here is some kind of
Round Table I think this was at America
Fest and Steve Bannon is just not happy
with the Trump nft grift and I
understand that it's really it's really
cringy I have a my pillow it's the best
all right that's right that's right
y'all speak I have the travel pillow I
have the slippers
it's all washable it's the most amazing
don't give her a promo code
there's other promo codes out there
ladies and gentlemen I'm just saying
just saying Mr Lindell and I I don't
need a promo code I tell everyone about
it thank you God bless you thank you if
we give the president a promo code can
he stop with the nfts I'm just kidding
I'm just kidding with the nfts that sold
out in 12 hours Steve's just jealous
over here yeah yeah I know that's a free
and fair market just yeah I mean listen
Bannon knows the entire Trump nft thing
is a complete and total grift and scam
and you can just tell he can't get away
from the humiliation of that we played a
clip yesterday of him saying whoever
came up with this idea should be fired
and it is very interesting in the sense
that some of the most reliable
historically reliable and stalwart Trump
supporters the confidants the Loyalists
they are now mocking Trump pretty
regularly and part of this maybe is the
polling that they're seeing maybe to
some degree the writing is on the wall
here's another example by the way here's
a clip of Matt Gates that I believe it's
the exact same event
saying that on the issue of who should
be speaker Donald Trump is wrong and
Gates is not the type of guy who would
typically uh distance himself or Draw
distinctions with Trump a couple of
unpleasant facts let's get him on the
table number one president Trump has
said the other day the New York Times
broke that he was whipping votes for
Kevin McCarthy and then president Trump
gave the great Matt Boyle at Breitbart
an exclusive interview and he said hey I
think Kevin's earned it president Trump
president president Trump is both
whipped votes here and he's come out and
told Breitbart and Matt Boyle that he's
actually supporting Kevin I adore what
about this is the Trump Posse right here
I can't wait to vote for Donald Trump in
the 2024 election but if Donald Trump
believes that Kevin McCarthy should be
speaker of the house then Donald Trump
is wrong and Donald Trump has not always
nailed it on the HR front I remember
having a fight against Jeff sessions and
Mattis and Rex Tillerson so president
Trump is the leader of our movement he
sets the vision but Donald Trump has not
moved a single vote when it comes to the
people considering how to cast their lot
in the speaker's race wow so not only
think about that not only is Gates
saying he disagrees with Trump about who
should be speaker of the house when
Republicans take over in January he's
saying Trump isn't even influencing even
a single person in the House of
Representatives to reconsider or change
how they are going to vote that's a
pretty serious attack from a guy who has
been a trump brown-noser for years at
this point in time and of course we'll
eventually know the answer but the
hypothetical is the supposition the
question is this a sign that the tide is
turning the polling is sort of
suggesting that and hearing from people
like Bannon and Gates suggests that that
also may be the way it is we'll know
more I believe
by something like April 1st I think it
will be pretty clear another really
interesting thing that's that's going on
is an intramaga Civil War let's talk
about that next when you're working
during the day when you're on the go and
you're in the mood for something sweet
don't reach for the candy bar go for
something that's just as good but
without the sugar and carbs our sponsor
monk pack makes delicious keto granola
bars and nut and Seed bars they're tasty
crunchy gooey sweet and salty I love
them but each bar has only one gram of
sugar two to three net carbs and about
150 calories perfect if you're doing
keto or low carb or low sugar you can
have a treat that feels indulgent and
satisfying without the guilt monk pack
comes in flavors like sea salt dark
chocolate caramel sea salt they just
launched two new flavors I love peanut
butter cocoa chip and dark chocolate
cocoa my favorite thing is the texture
I've tried a lot lot of these nut bars
granola bars monk pack is superior if
you don't agree you get your money back
and it is the perfect holiday gift go to
monkpak.com and get 20 off your first
order with the code Pacman the link is
down below